now that you're in your second season
have the Schmidt bans from new girl if
they have they accepted the new role I
hope so okay I'm a fan of Schmidt so I
love you in both no yes it's been really
cool you know there's still a lot of new
girl and Schmidt fans and you'll be
walking down the street and somebody
would it's it's yeah it was such a
wonderful experience and I love when I
get recognized for it and I'm so
grateful for it but now we have all
these people who are coming up to us for
the neighborhood yeah and they'll be
like I love your show and I'll go which
one and you sound like that guy I switch
one I have so many shows well I know but
I'm actually curious about it because
there's usually new girl and I'm like I
know but it's funny because now that
Netflix like takes over everything
except everybody that hasn't seen that
new girls but on like what's on for
years I'm like they're just now starting
well you can kind of guess like who's
coming up to you for what show because
you'll have some pinned out teen who's
like I love your show and you're like
did you just watch all seven seasons as
a new girl yeah and they're like yes and
it was amazing when you and Winston and
you're like alright man let's just let's
sit down let's like call every smash
this out everything's gonna be fine you
just need to breathe and have you heard
of the neighborhood yeah that's right
but then you'll have people who come as
like man I love the show you and Cedric
and like thought and it's been a really
like this show is is it's on CBS it's
really more of a family-oriented show
and so you're having conversations with
people who are like yeah you know we get
the whole family together we watch the
show it's got such a positive message
and we love doing the show that's a
great outlook so what kind of real-life
neighbor are you are you one that like I
feel like friends are you hide I feel
like I'm an I'm a nice neighbor because
I'm anticipating my kids like throwing
something breaking a window or the
neighbor of mine or like like being like
we should totally prank the neighbors
Mike my kids saying this like that's an
idea they would have I did this weird
thing I'm owning this on national
television but whenever I was a kid I
might mean my friend I don't know why we
did it but we would make like phone
calls and make would be like yeah we
want to go to have a flight to Jamaica
yeah we need to leave Tuesday the 16th
we're like laughing and it's not funny
it's not funny like it's not even funny
we're so stupid we weren't even like
funny at our joke no I know I did it and
we thought we were hilarious no I was
like well what was the crazy yeah what
was the prank and they'd be like yeah we
ordered a pizza and you rebel yeah this
is at least like nailed a bit funny
that's all right well are you the dad
who gets like over-involved are you a
helicopter dad you get really involved
that means yes you hesitated yeah yeah
you're like you're afraid they're gonna
fall off right you're always kind of
hovering I'm very like uh I mean I I've
gotten over that to some extent I'm very
like pleasee though meaning so you know
it's Halloween coming up yeah and so
last year there was an incident in which
my daughter went went to school sure and
her costume was Hermione Granger from
Harry Potter she was really excited we
were excited that's right that's right
she's cute so she was really excited and
she went to school she did like the
school parade and she came home and we
had we had where we live in like a good
neighborhood for trick-or-treating and
right before people were gonna come over
because we're having some people were
all gonna go out together she was like I
just hear it like a commotion than the
other room and I can see yeah I can hear
the tone is upset and I walk in I go
what's going on she's like I don't have
my cape and I go let's just throw on
like a t-shirt or something and she's
like no Hermione Granger is nothing
without her cave and I go whoa where is
it she goes I think I left it at school
I go I'll go to the school so I'd like
get in the car I run over the school
there's no cape I call the house from
the school phone and I'm like where is
it and she's like I don't know
so I finally am like I don't know what
to do I've been here 45 minutes I'm like
leaving I see that like in the corner of
the schoolyard this like bundled up
black piece of cloth and I go that can't
be it and I run over I pull it up and I
go this idiot
and so I run I run to my car at this
point I'm sweating I'm like barreling
through traffic peope they're about to
start to go out to like trick or treat I
get home I run through the door Lilly
and all her friends are like running
around and like here's your cape it's
like fix that and then runs off and
that's why I would have just given her
the sheet and now I appreciate and now
I'm like hyperventilating I'm like I'm
like dead I'm literally on the floor my
wife walks by and goes where have you
been you go up and beyond that's why
I've learned just don't just don't
yeah life will have disappointments this
is the first one I know I know
you're such a good person
I'm real I'm making up for a lot of
mistakes okay do you help with homework
like all that are you that kind of dad
big-time yeah you're so good there is a
part of me that's like we're getting
into some of her stuff and I'm like I
wonder how I'm gonna do in fourth grade
I should get tests back and she's like
she's like I got an 84 I'm like we got
an AV but I feel like the older they get
like they just get lazy about it if I'm
sitting there with them they'll be like
oh I don't know
I start getting me I don't know answer
and I'm out no you're just being lazy I
try to read like where they're at mental
yeah and I'm and I shouldn't say there
are tons for he doesn't get homework but
if she's Vermont if she's like wiped out
and you know she's got like she does a
lot after school subs in the basketball
team and I can see like she's we're
barely holding on yeah let's sit down
and do this together I know my moments
yeah but sometimes I'm like you're on
your own dude there's a lot of them like
you're just being lazy and want me to do
the problem I'm not gonna do it cuz I
don't know how to do fifth grade
like whatever Oh hope you nail it I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my YouTube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this